at this altitude I can run flat out for
a half mile before my hands start
shaking can I ask you a personal
question I must discover this episode of
the Tim Ferriss show is brought to you
by 99 designs 99 designs is a global
creative platform that makes it easy for
you to find an amazing designer and
create designs you'll love from logos to
branding to packaging to books you name
it they have it and I've used them for
just about everything 99 designs is the
go to creative resource for any budget
I've used them for years now for book
covers for instance mock-ups of the
4-hour body which went on to become a
number one New Times best seller
illustrations for the multi-volume Tao
of Seneca including the cover and many
other creative projects I've been very
impressed by the quality of their work
most recently I used 99 designs to
update the illustrations and layout of
my 5 morning rituals eBook
the illustrations worked out great I
loved working with the designer we
selected and I plan to work with him on
more projects in the future and that's
something you can do you don't have to
start from scratch every time and right
now my listeners can get $20 off plus a
free $99 upgrade on their first design
contest simply submit a brief on the
site describing what you need and
designers who are interested in your
project often from around the world will
submit concepts for you to choose from
you refined as you go give feedback and
once you're ready you choose one to
finalize it's a great way to get started
and find the right match a great
designer and a great design at a great
price so head to 99 designs com forward
slash Tim to learn more or get started
today you can also see examples of some
of the work that I have done with
designers on unending let's check it out
99 designs com forward slash tip
this episode is brought to you by fresh
books I've been talking about fresh
books for years now the all-in-one
invoicing payments and accounting
solution many entrepreneurs I know as
well as many contractors and freelancers
I work with all the time use it all the
time so I get to see fresh books on a
weekly basis fresh books makes it super
easy to track things like expenses
project time and client info and then
merge it all into great-looking invoices
fresh books can save users up to 200
hours per year on accounting and
bookkeeping tasks I don't know about you
but I like to do as little of that as
possible so 200 hours is a lot of hours
first books is always releasing new
features that make running your business
easier and here's just a few of the
major upgrades they've made in the last
twelve months alone number one they've
redesigned the time tracking feature to
create a more intuitive time tracking
experience number two they know just how
frustrating bank reconciliation can be
so they've automated bank reconciliation
removing the pain number 3 they've added
ACH bank transfers that means you now
have an even faster way to collect
payment from your clients it's easy to
see how freshbooks
can grow with your business and also
help your business grow it just gives
you more time to focus on growing the
business as opposed to running the
business and the admin stuff they have
plans to match your needs no matter the
size of your business from the basic to
comprehensive from small to big and it
all starts at just 15 dollars per month
right now they're offering it my
listeners that's you guys a free 30-day
trial of fresh books you can try it out
with no credit card no credit card is
required just go to fresh ebooks.com
slash to him and enter tim ferriss
that's two hours two S's in the how did
you hear about us section that's fresh
books com slashed him and enter Tim
Ferriss in the how did you hear about us
section check it out fresh books calm
slash Tim
well hello boys and girls this is tim
ferriss and welcome to another episode
of the tim ferriss show good day good
evening good afternoon wherever you may
be my gorgeous little Mogwai my guest
today is David Allen you may know of him
the man the legend you may worship his
systems or you may not know who he is so
I will tell you who David is one of the
world's most influential thinkers on
productivity
David's 35 years experience as a
management consultant and executive
coach have earned him the titles of
personal productivity guru by Fast
Company magazine and one of America's
top five executive coaches by Forbes
magazine the American Management
Association has ranked him among the top
10 business leaders full-stop his
best-selling book getting things done
subtitled the art of stress-free
productivity has been published in 30
languages and the GTD methodology as
it's known that it describes has become
a global phenomenon being taught by
training companies in 60 countries
probably more at the time of this
reading David his company and his
partners are dedicated to teaching
people how to stay relaxed and
productive in our fast-paced world you
can find him on twitter at GTD guy GTD
guy GUI and at getting things done
dot-com and without further ado please
enjoy a very wide-ranging very
unexpected in some aspects conversation
with David Allen
David welcome to the show delighted to
be here thanks to the invitation my
pleasure and it has been a very very
long time
since since we have had any contact I
know we were chatting before we we
pressed record it was probably just a
few weeks maybe a month after the 4-hour
workweek came out 2007 that I found
myself being interviewed by someone
alongside you virtually on the phone and
I was a nervous mess I was very
intimidated because I was like I was
stepping sort of into the arena with the
literal and metaphorical black belt in
the productivity space because also at
that time in 2007 GTD getting things
done was ubiquitous in Silicon Valley I
mean it was the talk of the town and 43
folders Merlin Mann and all of these
other outlets Lifehacker seem to talk
about GTD every day and so it's nice to
who it's nice to have a conversation
where I feel more comfortable asking
questions catching up well you know
folks like you had need time time is
somewhat irrelevant yeah and that's what
good friends are for you know it's like
you show up and go hey what's new
I don't two years 10 years yeah yeah
exactly
Edie I I was thinking back to that time
frame 2007 was a very important
inflection point for me if I want to
look at it that way and I around at the
same time somewhere between I want to
say 2007 2009 a friend of mine actually
interviewed you at South by Southwest in
a format that is very difficult I think
in some cases for both sides inside a
car his name is chase Jarvis yes I
remember that
he's such fun he's a phenomenal guy
brilliant photographer and he was trying
to do his best to squeeze out I and you
of course you're very good at providing
this but some type of nugget that he
could extract in say
minute or two minutes or however many
minutes it was and I thought we'd begin
there because the answer is I remember
it was your mind is made for having
ideas not for holding ideas and I think
this is is so important I would love to
hear you just expand on what that means
well your hands a crappy office and you
know most people are still using their
head as their office and your brain did
not evolve to remember remind prioritize
or manage relationships with more than
four things that's new
cognitive science data by the way so you
know how many people are trying to keep
track of more than four things and
manage the relationship between them and
prioritize between them's like excuse me
how about ten thousand fifteen hundred
or god knows however many and you know I
just sort of uncovered years ago more
practically and just on the street how
critical it was to empty your head and
again you know what the what then the
you know in the early days of the new
cognitive science feel they called
distributed cognition called get it out
of your head so I discovered that and
then discovered you know I just get it
out of your head but there are other
things you need to do to clarify back to
Peter Drucker like define what the work
is that you're getting out of your head
and what your kite is to it so so you
know that's I spent thirty the last
thirty five years trying to figure out
what that algorithm is and then spending
thousands of hours there's probably no
desk sought with some of the best and
brightest and busiest folks on the
planet actually implementing that
process and watching this
transformational happen stuff happen you
know
you know come on if you're you've done a
ton of coaching and advising I'm sure
and they know best advice is not to tell
people what to do but ask them the right
questions right they don't find out
what's going on in their head and help
them frame that in a way that's that's
useful and so I just you know I just
figured that out and it I don't how long
I'm gonna be preaching this to him you
know folks your head is not don't do
that don't leave your stuff in your head
and it's such a huge habit I think it's
because you know people have this I
think it gives people a false sense of
control to keep it in their head and
when they roll is the master addiction
you know so so
you know you've got to feel vulnerable
enough to unload everything that has
your attention and take a look at it
that's daunting I guess for most people
you been coaching said I'll jump to that
next I'd love to hear you describe what
you do with a say corporate client past
present hypothetical when you come in to
meet with say executives and their
individually very high-performing people
nonetheless carrying far more than four
items in each of their heads and you sit
down what what are the first questions
you ask or exercises you do when you sit
down with high functioning but
nonetheless overwhelmed people to work
with them what are some of the first
things that you do with them well aside
from establishing rapport right you know
hi and why why do you why did you bring
me in here
what is your presenting issue as best
you can describe it and you know and
here's a little bit about Who I am kind
of what we're gonna do but you know
ideally and over the years I discovered
the less I tell people about what we're
gonna do the better surprise so if I
just walked in cold you know the the
tabla rasa here is first thing I would
do Tim with you would be let's get let's
make sure you have an entry a physical
entry we have someplace to throw stuff
until we can make decisions about what
it means what you're gonna do about it
but we need to collect a bunch of stuff
first so that's what we're gonna do
first is get some sort of a material
version of collection or capturing stuff
that has people's attention so we just
get a big stack of printer paper a
favorite pen or pencil sit them down and
say okay what has your attention oh I
need cat food oh I need a life oh I need
a new vice president marketing Oh our
next vacation is coming up
oh my cell phone just just crapped out
the printer broke uh dad yeah and we
literally start writing they write each
one of those items that has their
attention on a separate piece of paper
and they tossed that into their entry
you'd be surprised by the way first
first of all how many people don't
happen in try or if they do have one
it's petrified because it's just been
sitting there with you know crap in it
for weeks we need to have some sort of
clear space to just collect all that
stuff to begin with that process Tim
takes usually in my experience over all
these years for the mid to senior level
professional that we actually coach with
this process it takes 1 to 6 hours just
to capture what has their attention not
to organize it not to prioritize it not
to make decisions about it just to
identify it yeah it's so impressive and
horrifying at the same time and I was
doing prep for this conversation
I found one paragraph that struck me is
important that's related to this I think
in some capacity this is from an older
piece in Wired but it reads as the
following so at a seminar Allan asked
the audience tread capture all their
stuff by writing a list at the end of a
few minutes tells us to look at the list
and think about the way it makes us feel
he guesses that our feelings include and
feel free to fact-check any of this by
the way a mixture of grief and relief
the relief he suggests comes from the
simple fact of making the list but where
does the grief come from and this is the
the quote that really caught my
attention these items represent
agreements you haven't kept with
yourself Allen says what happens when
you break in agreement with yourself is
that your self-esteem plummets could you
speak to this a bit because I would
imagine a lot of folks would say I feel
guilt perhaps about all the things I
haven't done for myself or for other
people but this grief and agreements
that you haven't kept with yourself
struck me as as important at least got
my attention good could you speak to
that well good a reverse-engineer it a
little bit mm-hmm and come back to the
the fact that you're breaking of the
agreement is because you're keeping
track of it in your head and where you
keep track of that has no sense of past
or future and so so that part of you
that little symbol party we think you
should be buying cat food 24 hours a day
president of 24 hours a day that's why
it wakes you up at 3 o'clock in the
morning oh because that thing has no
sense of past or future so because it
doesn't you can't do it all you can't do
both of one thing
and so there's a part of you that thinks
you should be doing all of that all the
time so talk about is done and broken
agreements yeah so you know but but you
don't have to finish the thing to keep
your agreement you do need to get it out
of your head you can see agreement
saying this is one of the things I
learned back in their own personal
growth days you know agreements you
there's an automatic price you pay when
you break an agreement is you just in a
great trust either with other people or
with yourself or both so if you don't
want to if you don't want to have a
broken agreement you have three options
one is don't make the agreement call no
I'm not gonna do that right move it to
some day maybe or something
keep the agreement go by go by the Katz
way to go hire the VP you know go finish
the thing or most importantly for most
people is renegotiate the agreement if
I've made an appointment
you know today for instance Tim is
people made here
ambient noise out there there's a
construction going on if that was too
loud I would probably have to try to
renegotiate and reschedule this this
talk with you and and and then I don't
have a broken agreement if I don't do it
because she ended it but you can only
feel good about what you're not doing
when you know what you're not doing so
most people just have just made so many
more agreements than they're aware of so
all we do our coaching is get people
aware of what are all the agreements
you've made what are all the would could
should need to adopt is and that's one
of the reasons people feel good when
they make a list as they look at me I go
well gee I can't do all this right now
no kidding right and so you know that
that's the that's the it comes back to
externalize there's stuff out of your
head that's why it's so critical to do
that and most people I don't think I've
really understood or certainly managed
themselves under with an understanding
of that dynamic
I'd love to to underscore and maybe dig
into a word that you used that I'm
certainly my own life trying to pay more
and more attention to which is really
renegotiate could you share perhaps any
recommendations that you give or perhaps
language you use yourself for
renegotiating Wendy what do you say to
someone whether via email or
was when you need to remove a commitment
whether it's forever or simply for
another time
do you have any particular suggestions
or thoughts related to yeah well I
there's probably I could probably think
of a dozen but one of the most
interesting ones and useful ones
sometimes is to make it really
politically correct it's like wow you
know what what you're asking me to do or
what I've committed to do is gonna
require so much more attention that I
have the bandwidth to actually give it
the attention it deserves right now can
we renegotiate that in terms of when
it's due or how we gonna make it happen
or if I even need to do it at all so
that's one way to do it mmm-hmm they
just say hey you know that's a cool
thing I don't mean this this is not bad
about you not even bad about me it's
like you know life changes and sometimes
we just have to renegotiate stuff in
that way you know I think it's important
to tell yourself as I say you can only
feel good about what you're not doing
when you know what you're not doing
that's why I've in order for me to be on
the the call with you and be present
here Jim I not long ago I looked at
every single thing I might could would
should be on to doing today and say no
this is it maybe I made a mistake we'll
find out right now but I just looked at
everything else it's hard to do if you
haven't seen everything else because you
don't know what everything else includes
and so you're not quite sure what you're
not doing and so most people then can't
truly renegotiate for themselves because
they're not sure order all the things
that they would could should ought to do
that's why Tim I mean it to another
point but it's ties very closely to it
when I'm not doing anything else I'm
cleaning up my backlog to zero because
there's a surprise coming toward me I
can't see and when that surprise hits
and it could be good bad or indifferent
but when that thing hits if I've got a
big backlog of unclarified on captured
on organized stuff I I'm gonna be
disturbed by any input even if it's good
because I don't know what else I'm
missing that if I decide to put my
attention on that new thing what's gonna
be missed what's gonna fall to a crack
somewhere
so that's why I'm keeping it clean you
know keeping the backlog as minimal as
possible it's just a fabulous way to
just make sure that you know that you're
clear about what are all the agreements
that you have renegotiated with yourself
yeah that makes that makes very good
sense that's it's on the weather this
will turn out to be the best use of your
time you give me give me a perhaps
another half-hour to dissapoint we'll
see how it turns out on the on the
backlog as minimal as it may be where
does that physically live for you
currently what is that what is the the
holding pen for that for you uh
primarily two and a half places one is
obviously email you know right now I'm
just because of some other stuff that's
going on I have about a screen and a
half full of email which is a little
little too much for my comfort zone but
that's okay it all I'll clean it up a
little bit later my physical entrer that
I'm staring at right now which happens
to be empty you know while I was waiting
for the construction site to slow down a
little bit out there I was processing a
bunch a bunch of receipts that you know
my wife and I collect in the last 24
hours putting them in to quicken so
that's all zeroed out right now and the
other half place is my little note
ticker wallet that I carry around with
me that has a one note in it that says
chiropractor okay so I'm just throwing
that into my entry right now so those
are the those are the places I capture
really I don't capture much digitally I
do have an iPhone digital capture called
brain toss a great little program that
to GT deers you know and Amsterdam
actually actually built because what it
does is it doesn't put it into the black
hole of my iPhone an automatic transfer
transfers it to my email so if I care to
digitalize anything that I'm capturing
some thoughts some idea what our picture
I want to take of something whatever it
automatic good goes to email which then
I clean up like I clean up a email
regularly but those are the main places
what are the benefits of minimizing the
digitizing so to speak are are there
benefits is it simply a habit that
you have continued overtime since that's
where it started or are are there are
there features to using and there's two
sides to the coin but the digital world
I mean first of all it's a great time to
be alive if you know what you're doing
and you've got a little discipline if
you don't it's a black hole and you're
like to get throw stuff in that you
uncovered you know of the month later go
oh my god I should handle that and it's
didn't do you put it in Dropbox you just
take it and Evernote you and put it in
Outlook you want to put it in whatsapp
what the word we're gonna stick this
stuff so the plethora of options has
made it almost more work you know come
on oh I don't know if you've seen all
the studies that say the basically
productivity hasn't gone up at all
though technology has gone to the roof
you know a lot of that is because the
technology hasn't necessarily improved
productivity it's actually complicated
people's lives a lot I know a bunch of
high tech people that have gone back to
paper planners especially the a DD and
ADHD type because they're too many
clicks and out of sight out of mind
you know I've got a thunderbolt screen
but I still don't have the real estate
on there that I used to have with my
time design paper planner you can't beat
it because you can see all of that sort
of a relationship to each other much
easier it's there no clicks as no
battery no Wi-Fi required it has all the
downside I mean I'm a kind of a high
tech end user anyway I like I like all
that stuff because of connectivity and
so forth but if you really need to know
what you're doing otherwise the techni
tech world can really be quite
overwhelming mm-hmm and I think what I'd
love to do is is rewind the clock a bit
to get a better understanding of how you
became the current version of David
Allen could you describe where you were
in high school what you were focused on
at the time if anything and and what you
want it to be what you thought you would
be when you grew up or what you want it
to be when you grew up
yeah well I had to rewind take quite a
bit um let's see high school oh well
first of all I was an actor as a kid
wait before high school when I was 10 11
12 years old like I took an acting
lessons and actually became sort of the
child star in Shreveport Louisiana where
I I pretty much that most of my growing
up years and so that was always kind of
a love was that then in high school I
became a debater and state champion
debater regional champion debater
whatever so I enjoyed I loved debating
that was fun
standing up and trying to make it up you
know kind of while you're on your feet
and I thought I was you know you know
come on we're talking the 50s and early
60s and in Shreveport Louisiana if you
had any brains at all you were either a
lawyer a doctor or a teacher you know if
you weren't necessarily that you know in
that line of things you either sold cars
or insurance or something like that that
was pretty much yet you know they would
we're a whole lot of other up consultant
what's that you know actor no go get a
good degrees you know so that you have a
job so there weren't a whole lot of
options basically in my head it turns
out I actually had the opportunity we
had an exchange student at our high
school that I was going to from Germany
and that kind of that was of interest to
me and so I actually applied to the
American field service AFS and back then
there were not many Americans that that
of foreign families or international
families would actually take an American
for a whole year
use the Americans went for the summer
but I applied for the whole year I said
what the heck and turns out I was able
to I got chosen Lance family in Zurich
Switzerland what lived the Swiss family
for a whole for a whole year and that
was eye-opening how old were you at the
time 17 at 18
Wow actually 63 64 I was over there when
Kennedy was shot which was quite
traumatic for most of the Europeans
anyway you know when that happened but
you know I went to the basically the
high school that the boys in the family
went to there wasn't an academic program
it was more social live with the family
see how the
live and so forth so I went to really
give nauseam to an experiment which
happened to be a block up from the kunst
house in Zurich that had Monet water
lilies from you know all over the walls
and I was three blocks from the Odeon
cafe which is where dadaism started
we're young and you know you know so I
was thrust into the middle of European
history and culture just by being there
and that kind of opened my eyes a good
bit also I had a turned out ahead I had
I had a half-sister much older than me
who had wound up marrying one of the
intellectual chroniclers of The Beat
Generation a man named John Cleland
Holmes if you ever looked up John Holmes
John Cullen Holmes you know you run some
very interesting books and they lived in
Connecticut they were very very hip my
dad died when I was really young and my
mom when I was dying took me to visit
Chile and John her husband and so I got
I got introduced to probably the hippest
of the hip in terms of of intellectual
you know culture New York City Manhattan
beat but I think my brother-in-law John
and and Kerouac coined the term beat you
know together you know watching somebody
kind of beat themselves you know walk
down Central Park anyway so I got
introduced early on to a whole new
different world of sophistication and
you know and culture really back down so
I wasn't I wasn't kind of blindsided by
the fact that the world was a lot bigger
than you know my world I was growing up
in in Louisiana so I kind of wanted to
get out of there as soon as I could
nothing nothing against that I still
love Louisiana are still going back and
you know sort of seeing the culture and
the food and the bayous and so forth and
all that but I certainly my world had
expanded by that point and you know I
was interested in sort of pursuing that
so I didn't know I thought law maybe to
begin with but then after being in
Switzerland being around all that
culture then the interest of the liberal
arts philosophy so forth was much it was
more interesting to me so when I got
into college that was my focus in what
did what for those who aren't familiar
with the the career path so to speak
what did that what that look like
some crazy little college in Florida
their design your own education no
grades independent study called new
college and god I've got bored by the
philosophers they wound up proving their
original hypothesis using their original
hypothesis is kind of that's kind of a
circle thing but what's more interesting
was the philosophers themselves and I
had a great friend he turned out to be
he was my academic adviser turned out to
be a good friend who was an intellectual
historian history of thought so he
turned me on to history of culture
history of thought I thought I was
really cool and we didn't even use the
word paradigm back then but that's what
I got introduced to I read Oswald
Spengler the decline of the West which
is one of the earliest books you know
hundred over a hundred years ago talking
about cultures having their own psyche
their own Geist and how that affected
art philosophy math science medicine you
know and everything because you there
was kind of a thumbprint or a signature
in the various cultures that you could
see through all of those things so I was
fascinated by that so I guess that was
kind of the early stages of me being
interested in models you know well
understanding a model if we could
understand a model with it that could
help the world make a lot more sense
I've always been somewhat attracted to
that always also been attracted by how
the invisible affects the visible if you
look back in my career you know my first
job was a magician at age five on the on
the sidewalks of Palestine Texas I
charged five cents for my magic show so
you could trace it if you kind of
stretch a little bit but you could trace
it all the way back to there no I will
always been fascinated by how if we
could understand what's going on
invisibly that's affecting everybody and
get a hold of it that could make a huge
difference in how you manage your life
mm-hmm and it seems like you tried your
hand at many different types of jobs and
we certainly don't have to trace through
all of them but how did you end up
teaching say corporations or
productivity which at which you're in a
and and that may not be the yeah how
would you
I'll make a very long story very short
you know I got I got into graduate
school in American intellectual history
now again this is Berkeley 1968 they say
if you can remember being in Berkeley in
1968 you probably weren't there so so
but that was heady times to be there and
then you know at some point I realized
wait a minute I really wanted to get my
own enlightenment instead of just study
people who had theirs so I just figured
that academia was not the place for it
and so I had jumped ship you know left
that said okay
and then I got went on my own personal
exploration path you know lots of things
you know lots of drugs but also martial
arts spiritual stuff you know come on
this is the 60s this is Berkeley you
know in early 70s so as I studied all of
that I was more interested in finding
out who I was and finding out about God
truth in the universe and having a job
but of course rice bowl and cave wasn't
my style so I said okay I got to pay the
rent so how do I do that well so that I
had a I had several friends who
themselves kind of knew what they wanted
to do and they were starting their own
businesses and you know running small
businesses and so I wound up being a
good number 2 guy so just just have a
good job I helped some but I helped two
guys start a new orleans-style
restaurant in LA I helped a friend run a
landscape company in San Fernando Valley
I sold mopeds you know you could read
the list of Wikipedia it's a lot of
stuff that I did but I was just
basically I would go in and say well how
can I help them do what they're doing
and how much easier can we make this
because I'm just a lazy guy and and you
know then I'd help improve their but now
we call that process improve but but I
was just trying to you know not have to
work so hard and and then I went fixed
and then I get bored so then I go find
another job and then I discovered one
day they call those people something
they pay them they call consultant you
know so 1981 hung out my shingle a loved
associate couldn't spell it now I are
one so then I said okay well let me see
if I can sort of just throw myself
about their project by project with
people and you know make that work but
then again because I didn't want to have
to work so hard I thought well I'm
really interested in models that would
work in case I can't see you know
obviously how to help somebody in their
process it'd be nice if I had a model in
my back pocket to pull out and be able
to help them that would somehow improve
their condition so I got very hungry for
those models also because of my
meditation spiritual work martial arts
work I really love the idea of being
clear in my head you know it's sort of
been you know a lot of training in the
martial arts about how do you clear your
head you know so you can fight
appropriately and but then my life got
more complex I said but that's kind of
screwing up my clear head so both my
interest in keeping a clear head as well
as you know good models to help people
had me start to get attracted to and
pull in piece by piece you know and
fast-forward all the stuff that became
ultimately GTD and getting things done
you know 20 years later but there was no
grand Epiphany I there was just little
small epiphan EPS along the way that I
began to cobble together in a system in
a systematic approach and you know I
found some stuff that worked for me you
know I had a couple of mentors teach me
some of the key elements of these things
you know what god that's really cool and
then I turned around and use those
techniques with my own clients and it
produced the same result more clarity
more focused more meaningful space in
their head and I thought well that's
cool so that became a key part of my my
own consulting we didn't call it
coaching back then we're just consulting
and then I you know head of HR and a big
corporation saw what I was doing I said
wow we need that in our whole company
David can you design a training program
you know with this methodology so we can
reach a lot of people with this stuff so
I spent a couple of months is designed
at two and a half day personal
productivity training and we did a pilot
program for a thousand executives and
managers at Lockheed 1983 and 84 and
that worked hit a nerve and I found
myself thrust into the corporate
training world could have fooled me if
you told me as an American intellectual
history major in Berkeley in 1968 that
I'd be in the corporate training world
I'd say what do you smoke
[Laughter]
but it turned out that that they happen
to happen to be the audience that was
most attracted to what I had found out
because the world they you know the mid
to senior level professionals were just
starting to get hit with stuff like
email and that tsunami of stuff that was
starting to hit the corporate world and
they were also the clients that were
interested in actually paying for
training and coaching and so forth you
know that would assist you know people
in those roles so that's how I that's a
very short version of a very long story
I appreciate the the background I would
love to hear a bit more about your
mentors so there any particular mentors
who were particularly important to the
formation of GTD there were two and I
just had him on stage with me in
Amsterdam because I invited them too you
know we just did the GTD global summit
and I wanted people to sort of hear some
of the original DNA of where GTD started
one was Dean Acheson the other was
Russell Bishop and Dean was a had been a
25-year consultant and in executive
consulting in organizational change and
he had he had uncovered the techniques
that were critical to be able to loosen
people up so they were able to make
change instead of having a lot of old
business prevent them from being able to
to do that so the whole idea of a mind
sweep getting stuff out of your head I
learned from Dean he had figured that
out that that was absolutely critical
for executives particularly because you
know if they had all this old business
spinning around on their head for them
to buy into his own new goal and vision
was like swimming in quicksand
so he discovered they're getting that
stuff out of their head and having them
make next action decisions the very
specific next action so I learned the
mind sweep and the next actions from
Dean and those are still core core
elements that anybody needs you know to
get clarity you know it gets your head
clear you know terms of your commitments
and Russell Bishop was the co-founder of
insight seminars which was a sort of
personal growth self-development thing
that I got involved in in 78
and you know I love that I love that
training and a large part of that
training were was about commitments so I
learned about commitments there and how
powerful that was and it was a
transformative experience for me and
then I actually became a trainer for
insight seminars working working with
Russell and we were designing some sort
of personal productivity workshops and
we were being brought into the corporate
world back in the seventies late 70s
early 80s a lot of the corporate world
was started to be interested in sort of
what the personal growth had to offer
actualization is life spring insight you
know things like that were suddenly
being brought into the corporate world
it was a little dangerous because you
know you had to be a little vulnerable
you know most corporate cultures were
not you know not that open for all of
that kind of stuff but it was an
interesting you know experiment and
foray into that world and so I worked
with Russell we we created the insight
Consulting Group and we started to do
you know these you know what I had
learned both from Dean and in my own
work we started to do versions of this
stuff in the corporate world
and that's where you know Russell was my
partner for many years that's that's
where a lot of that started I'd love to
dig into next action decisions this is
this is a really powerful concept and a
really important distinction that many
people do not have a whole lot of
clarity on could you talk about next
action decisions and how they perhaps a
differ from what a lot of people put on
their to-do lists sure well when we talk
about next actions that means as
granular as we're physically visibly are
you going to go to do what to move the
needle on this thing on this commitment
is that at your computer to write an
email is that at your computer to search
a website is that at the hardware store
to buy nails is that at your
life-partner to have a conversation what
is the very very next thing you need to
do to get clarity on mom's birthday or
increasing your bank credit line or
hiring a vice president or getting a
life
very next section if you had nothing
else to do but that would you go do and
people avoid that decision like the
plague they do could have fooled me
but you know it takes you know when we
coach people it takes 1 to 6 hours for
them to identify all the stuff they have
attention on and then the rest of the
day or two to go through each one of
those and say okay what's the next thing
you need to do about cat food about vice
president about get a life about should
you get divorced or not you know what's
the next thing and you know and it takes
people actually have to think to make
those decisions it's not hard there are
actually two aspects of getting clarity
that that you know that I have to tie
together is what's the very next action
and if one action won't complete
whatever this commitment is what's the
project you know people if you look at
most people's to-do list you think you
see things like mom you know in Bank
yeah well I'm sure you had a mom so why
is it on the list well or birthdays
coming what are you gonna do buy your
birthday right so you know so taking
something like that and then well you
captured the idea great so you that's
step one but then step two is you need
it then clarify what exactly you're
gonna do about that and you know what's
the final outcome so give mom a birthday
party goes on my project list and call
sis my sis to see you know what she
thinks we got to do for mom's birthday
is the next action as simple as that
sounds
outcome and action are the zeros and
ones of productivity but most people
have not actually identified the
outcomes and the specific actions you
know other things that have their
attention good a fool me but they're
very few people that are exceptions to
that and most people have tons and stuff
anybody listening to this right now just
pull out your to-do list and I'll let's
show you what I'm talking about
you know and you most of the things on
your to-do lists are not the the very
next action you need to take about those
and probably the things on your to-do
list are not the complete outcome that
you're trying to achieve by whatever you
action you need to take so it's funny
that that the zeros ones of productivity
people are avoiding make getting things
done you need to know what done means
you get to market offers complete when
once
true and what is doing look like it
where does it happen oh that's a phone
call or that's a thing to buy at the
store or that's a conversation I need to
have with somebody so I know it's kind
of a duh Jim but it's it is something
that most people are need to train a
cognitive muscle to answer those
questions about stuff because it
requires thinking families hard that's
its it also requires a sort of a reframe
as to what a an affective to-do list or
an X action list looks like even the
label itself right should I be using the
term to refer to mom bank etc as a to-do
list what does that actually mean when
applied to bank it all caps and in our
case it would just be your your capture
list captured that was good great then
you need to throw those in your in frame
and then go through this decision-making
process
is it actionable yes or no if no it's
either reference or trash or incubate if
yes then it is okay so what's the next
action and if one action won't complete
it what's the project so as simple as
those questions are that's how you get
your in basket empty not by finishing
everything yeah anything you can do at
two minutes you should finish right then
that's the two minute rule but but
otherwise you just need to clarify it
and then you know step 3 would be
organized the reminders in some
appropriate place I would love to talk
about and and please feel free to
rephrase this or take a different angle
if better but sort of top-down versus
bottom-up systems and specifically I've
looked at a number of listener questions
that that were posed and one was related
to after doing a mine sweep and sorting
the results and to do it to Skaar to
delegate it to fur it some people still
having an extremely large list after
discarding aggressively and not being
sure of how to then eliminate more if if
there are tasks or items that they can
simply discard things that are not worth
doing
I was just gonna say how you help people
to if they say I don't know what is
important or I'm not sure how to
prioritize things if you have any advice
or thoughts for those people sure I got
a bunch one way to think about it is is
from a hierarchical standpoint of
priorities you know one of the things
that you know I uncovered over all these
years is the six horizons that we
actually have commitments and they're at
different levels with different content
the top horizon would be what's your
life purpose or what's the purpose of
your now you can do this iterate
iterated on your company or any
enterprise you want but let's do it
let's talk about personal so why are you
on the planet what are your to do you
know what's your purpose obviously
that's gonna set your priorities right
you don't want to be off purpose so
that's the top level of course knowing
your purpose is not going to help you
decide which email to write first a
little bit you know but then the next
level operationally and I say down not
as less it just means it's more
operational would be what's the vision
of your purpose being fulfilled
successfully five years from now Jim
where'd he want to be what does your
lifestyle look like you know I'm sure
living in New York as opposed to Silicon
Valley was some part of a vision that
you had as opposed to you know you know
just day-to-day so you had some sort of
a picture about hey if I really want to
do kind of what I want to do here's what
it would look sound and feel like so
that's the vision level that people have
in companies that be three four five
year you know long term plan or vision
in terms of where does company want to
be now knowing the vision that you have
in terms of life and career and
lifestyle does that can help you decide
which email is most important yeah a
little bit more that then there's a next
level operationally which is down from
that which is goals and objectives so
what do you if you wanted that vision to
actually come true what do you need to
accomplish over the next three to 24
months that'd be usually what people
talk about in terms of annual plans and
so forth yeah well I need to make sure
my kids get into college I need to make
sure that we you know that we set up
this new division I need to you know I
want to publish the book you know
whatever whatever those things are those
would be goals that that are emerged as
a way to get to your vision
that's so purpose it be horizon five
horizon forward be up you know vision
horizon three would be goals and
objectives horizon two importantly is
all the things that you need to maintain
that are important to you to maintain so
that you get there that you're balanced
and you're moving in the right direction
so personally this be how's your health
how's your finances how's your
relationships how's your spiritual life
how's your dog how's your fun vector you
know whatever all those things are that
you say I need to maintain these you
don't finish that you just need to make
sure that they're up to par I'm just
getting you where you want to go
so that's horizon to in your
organization's that would be your job
description what are the things you're
accountable to do well asset management
staff development you know cut a
customer service project design you know
yadda yadda so that'd be looking at
those levels there and saying okay well
once you define your job description
once you looked at your aspects of your
life that's gonna help you to decide a
little bit more about what's the most
important email you you need to send
then you get more operational say well
what are all the things you need to
finish about any of those things of both
projects you know and most people have
between 3,100 get tires on your car
handle the next vacation hire the person
get a dog research whether I can give my
kids karate lessons or not yeah Anna so
then that's the project level that's
horizon one and then the ground level we
use ground and then one two three four
five late elevators in Europe as opposed
to you know the US since we're so
international now so we had to change in
my the first book I called five thousand
fifty thousand feet and forty thousand
and so forth but they don't use feet in
Europe and so anyway so then the ground
level is what all the things you need to
do that's the actions you need to take
and most people have 100 to 200 of those
emails to send stuff to by the store
stuff to talk to people about etc so
when you say how do I set my priorities
and say well which one of those horizons
is not clear enough to you needs it
needs more work or which one do you need
to refer back to to then decide what's
most important on your list so that's a
and that's a big conference
as you can imagine for most people to
try to figure that out but I didn't you
know I tried to get it as simple as I
could but I can't lie to anybody that is
the though that's the truth those are
all things that are either conscious or
not they're still they're still at
effect for everybody and so being aware
of what your content is on all those
different levels is going to help a lot
will help a ton on a more simple
practical level
I just set priorities they say what's
most got my attention what's both got my
attention right now what what most do I
need to handle so I get to clear space
again and you know so at this point in
my life I'm not that kind of simplified
let's let's talk about location for a
second because this is this is something
that I'm certainly very curious about
and think about a fair amount I'm in New
York right now for writing because I
have a very set writing routine here in
New York and it's I'm also pretty
isolated in rural New York the move that
I made from Silicon Valley to Austin
Texas was certainly dependent on my
answers and descriptions to those higher
levels that you described mm-hmm and I
I'm sure this is written somewhere but I
didn't want to try to research
everything before the conversation
Amsterdam why did you move to Amsterdam
or were the drivers are the reasons
behind that well there's kind of a
perfect storm of a lot of factors one is
we want to get out of the US we were a
bit tired of us centricity in terms of
thinking and we thought about we love
Kyoto we loved other places but Europe
Europe seemed to be that the place they
could go Maya Catherine my wife and I
don't have kids and so you know a little
freer to do that my work was becoming
much more virtual and actually much more
global and Amsterdam is much more the
center of my world these days in Santa
Barbara was and we've been to the city a
couple of times and fell in love with it
we love the city it's an eye candy city
Ames just gorgeous and it's and it's
lovely and we kind of naively thought
well it's been three months there in six
months in Milan in six months and
whatever because
now that my work was becoming so virtual
you know we have the ability to be able
to do that of course once we found out
what it takes to be legal and get legal
residency in any place you know there's
a lot of Hoops to jump through and it
turns out that and we just kind of threw
a darts at Amsterdam it was warmer and
not quite as dark as Copenhagen or
Stockholm a little more foreign you know
and adventurous then then London and
everybody here speaks English so you
know that was easy and you know once we
were here at the quality of life here is
just so wonderful and we just pull love
with the city even more so and still are
five years later so we intend to stay
it's been a fact we wanna have a great
so and it gonna be we love the Dutch we
love the country now but golly it's just
Oh ASA so you know global thinking and
openness or whatever that's kind of rare
in the world these days it is it is
definitely one of my favourite cities in
the world you mentioned a lot of
wonderful places but Amsterdam really
does check so many boxes it's it's a
marvel of a city it really is it really
is it works you know we haven't had a
car in five years it just works you know
and you know and we have gather and I
both have two bikes apiece we walk
gorgeous parks it's a very dog-friendly
city our favorite restaurants let you
know allow dogs that's worth moving to
[Laughter]
have you found your state of being
whether it's your emotional state mental
state if if it differs at all to differ
being say in Amsterdam after a number of
years versus being in California not
really that much come on Santa Barbara
is a gorgeous place it's not exactly the
heart the hard streets of only two years
and we loved that we thought we could be
there permanently as a beautiful place
wonderful place great people you know a
great style of a
like sort of a country place to live and
and so it kind of surprised us that all
of a sudden we just felt like we were
done you know I call it Dharma karma
destiny whatever it is it's like somehow
just you know there are times in our
lives when just things just are over and
so we haven't missed anything at all it
didn't really change quality of life
here is just so nice and that's nice to
do it every day I know straight people
are those straight dogs here as opposed
to California did so what was it a a
lingering desire over time maybe we
should move maybe we should move or was
there an event or a day or a
conversation where you just said this is
it we're done it kind of was a four or
five year moved sort of some day maybe
two yeah let's kind of start to see if
we can get real about it we had built
our own little sort of jewel box office
building in Ojai so we needed to kind of
unhook from that our house that we that
we bought in 1992 was so gorgeous it was
like God Laker out on East End of Ojai
it's just a beautiful property I had old
Oaks and then it was so forth it would
but it was kind of a teardown house to
begin with we just couldn't afford to
tear it down and rebuild and we
discovered the termites don't move that
fast so so basically we just built a
huge garden around it now we had one
acre and we just built outdoor fireplace
we had a stunning garden we had a
fabulous friend who was a landscape
gardener and that was just you know so
we just had a great time we just lived
outdoors so that was that was wonderful
then the termites started to win and we
said you know with Katharine my style
and our inclinations we would have
rebuilt it with glass and concrete and
and you know and iron you know in in
that environment it would have been just
gorgeous there but we didn't have the
money to do that so we said you know
let's just put a price on the house and
it would the market was crap at the time
we said you know probably nobody is
going to show up at a little bit but
let's just put a price on it what the
heck you know it would be an emotional
buy anyway and we say figured that maybe
one or two years so I don't know
two weeks later somebody walked on her
said I want it right for that price I
went oh this might be a sign so so we
got out from under the house and we said
but we weren't quite ready to move to
Europe at the time there was still more
work I needed to do sort of there and
locally with the business and so we said
well let's kind of get trailer wheels so
we then got a townhouse in Santa Barbara
that we were at for three years and you
know we sort of has got trailer wheels
for Europe we got dutch bikes and we
lived in a town house close to town we
could walk into town and so forth so
that was kind of our transition moved
there and then at a certain point we
said okay let's throw the dart time to
go that's what we did off you went yeah
it is it seems to be landing on the
radar more and more of my American
friends as a is a possible home base
it's it's it really is a wonderful
choice it's full its full
they hate dogs stray people everywhere
there are certain decisions at least in
my life I would imagine in your life
that are our real chapter changes and
end up in forming many many things that
come thereafter I love to ask you what
is one of the most worthwhile or the
best personal investments you've ever
made and I'll explain what I mean that
could be money time energy anything else
so for instance if if I ask 20 Robins
that he would point to a Jim Rohn
seminar that he paid for at the time
when he was working as a janitor if I
talked to Amelia Boone who's a four-time
world champion and obstacle course
racing she'd say the first time she
cobbled together the fees to pay for one
of the larger competitions which then
ended up showcasing how well built and
designed she was for this sport does
does does anything come to mind as a
particularly important investment that
you made that
long standing ripple effects you know
yeah I mean they're probably a dozen but
I'll tell you one that comes to mind I
don't think I've shared this with many
people but as you mentioned that that
what what pops to mind is I had a guy
that became a very good friend of mine
and a mentor of mine many many years ago
that I met in Berkeley and he was the
guy who offered to teach me karate and
he was quite an interesting guy and he
was a olympic fencer he was a Formula
racer he had black belt in karate he was
just a fascinating he was also a psychic
he was studied by the University of
Pennsylvania just because of experiences
that he had and things that he saw and
things that he knew and back in the
early days when you know universities
are starting to study this psychic
phenomena and where it came from and
Michael became a very close friend of
mine and as he started to teach me
karate I found my life started to change
and and I suddenly I kind of been doing
all the things that were that that were
called to do and that sort of were
expected of me to do you know I'd been a
straight-a student I gone to a very hip
and cool College obviously I got to
graduate school and had good grades
married it you know beautiful woman got
a house at Berkeley I mean this is you
know as cool a license one could have
and then one day I woke up and realized
this wasn't the life I wanted that there
was adventure that I that I was holding
myself back from that there were things
I wanted to explore and expand and so
forth that I I wanted to do and that
sort of changed me you know one day I
just decided to not go back to school
and I have no idea kind of records the
University of California Berkeley has
with me but I just didn't go back I said
not not for me
so left my marriage lift my life left
all of that and then embarked on a inner
and outer adventure that was quite
adventurous you know I I ran into you
know a lot of stuff about me after I ran
into a
false starts and a lot of things that
didn't work very well but there was all
in my exploration it wasn't really
escape I was just looking in exploring
awful lot of things and then found more
and more stable waist and more inner
ways to do you know in a with a much
much more consciousness and stability
and then kind of random and ad-hoc so I
kind of grew up from that you know over
the years and answered my outer life
became blocked quieter even though my
inner life was still quite rich so I
suppose that that was that was a
hallmark event you know was for me to
make that decision to leave what people
would probably consider was you know one
of the best in Google's kind of
lifestyles you would have and you know
go on my own trip was that a difficult
decision I mean and I hate to sound like
a broken record but it was it was this a
kind of one day I'm done or was it
something that developed over time I
mean that's a lot of people don't leave
situations that well days or weeks or
months but certainly wasn't I don't
think it was months I think was probably
weeks that I had that fought but you
know and I'm mister approval stuck on
you know I like people's approval I
don't you know I don't I don't like
being the rebel and being out you know I
like people to like me
and so that was that was tough what was
the conversation like with your your
wife with your partner at the time not
yeah I mean was it just short like I'm
leaving today or was it more of a leta
more lead time than that and I just I
didn't know I didn't understand myself
well enough and I'm not comfortable
enough in my own skin to know how to
engage with that so it was kind of a it
was radical you know god bless her she
she endured it as well as anybody could
I suppose but it you know I was not a
class act in terms of how I did that the
the mentor that you mentioned earlier my
listeners will kill me if I don't return
to at least one description of this
mentor the
the psychic abilities or extrasensory
abilities that led to him being studied
by as you mentioned the University of
Pennsylvania did you observe were you
able to observe any of this or - oh yeah
what what what types of things did you
observe well you would see certain
things in other words you would have a
vision of something and say by the way I
know this person did XYZ and they indeed
that's exactly what they did or what
they were going to do so he just had an
extra sensory perception ability for
that you know in his own story he's now
dead but he did he told the story you
know he he was quite depressed as a kid
and didn't know he just had was so
sensitive and didn't understand where
people were doing what they were doing
and so he did all kinds of things to try
to compensate for that and all these
sports things that he was extremely good
at and then one day he went to sleep and
was taken out of his body and was shown
other levels why he'd been going through
all the experiences he had and it was
going to be coming toward him and that
he would have this job essentially the
Karma of being able to share what he had
learned with them because he owed him so
I turned out I was one of those people
at least according to him so that's you
know that's kind of cool and but there
may be some people listening to this
know what I'm talking about
ya know I pursue you sharing the story I
yeah this is this is something we could
talk a lot much longer about but I will
try to sort of keep the thread of the
the last question in the sense that many
of the listeners who asked questions
they would hope I would explore with you
ask something along the lines of what
Nick dobos Act which is asked excuse me
which is how does he deal with things
like mental fatigue motivation and moods
role and productivity I'm gonna I'm
going to push that from a from a
sideways angle and kind of related to my
last question which is could you
describe a particular
a difficult period that you face because
it's it's very you've done a lot of
incredible things you have GTD being
taught as I understand it in sixty plus
countries probably at this point massive
success on so many objective levels I
really like to humanize guests by asking
about tougher times and how they got
through it or found their way through it
would you be open to describing any
particular tough or dark period that you
went through and how you made your way
through it
sure well you know back in my early
Berkeley days I had a really interesting
time where I was having my own kind of
sort of psychic or spiritual experiences
and didn't understand where they came
from and didn't understand why other
people didn't understand them and so you
know though I'd been sort of mr. nice
guy suddenly I found myself outcast and
that was you know quite painful so I
wound up you know involved in sort of a
berated behavior out of my frustration
of all that and they put me away in a
mental institution
which I thought was kind of interesting
because at the time I could see as much
about what was going on with the people
who put me there as as anybody in there
and I thought well that's kind of
fascinating just to be able to see all
that and I'd read you know much of the
literature about you know is crazy
really crazy or are you tapped into
something you know very different so I
knew I was tapped into something very
different but couldn't get anybody to
understand that so and then it became
quite painful and it's a certain point I
said well you know this is too painful I
think I'm gonna decide to cooperate
instead of rail against these people
that can't see what's going on so as I
say I never really got cured you're just
looking at a high state of cooperation
so I managed to get and it wasn't very
long but it was you know how long how
long were you in Oh a couple of weeks a
couple of weeks if I could if I could
interrupt for just a second what were
the behaviors that led you to end up
there and
how did you end up there I mean was it
family friends no I got really pissed
off at my mentor friend and he knew that
you know I was I would kind of had gone
off the rails and I threw a brick
through his window and so he called the
cops and the cops put me away anyway
that that's it's a much longer more
intricate story than that but that's the
simple very moment and so you decided to
cooperate and you get released what what
what did your life look like for the the
weeks following that experience well I
got a job you know and you know sort of
straightened myself up and started to
cooperate with the world and then that's
when I discovered you know a whole lot
of I wasn't sure what had happened to me
but I was walking down the street in
Telegraph Avenue in Berkeley and walked
into a store called Shambhala bookstore
and I walked in I don't know why just
intuitively and I looked around and I
looked down on the shelf and I saw this
book that said the gateways to spiritual
science by Rudolf Steiner I said oh I
wonder if there are people who actually
know what all this stuff is really about
and so I spent the next oh three or four
or five months exploring huge amounts of
the esoteric literature of the occult
and you know the white Brotherhood and
all kinds of stuff that I didn't know
anything about but there's a whole body
of literature but theosophist to begin
with in the late 18-hundreds early
nineteen hundred's Europe that were sort
of studying the science of spirituality
essentially and dug into that like crazy
I said oh my god you know I'm not so
crazy you know i depth into something
that there was something to tap into so
then started to go on an exploration to
see if I could find somebody who knew a
lot more about that than I did and
that's when I discovered a guy named
John Roger who then wound up being my
spiritual coach I said so hung out with
him said well I'll see how much I can
learn from him and that was you know 45
years and he was just further down the
path and I was but had a lot of that
information so that that's when my life
sort of my outer my outer life you know
got much simpler and much more calm
and traditional my inner life you know
got quite rich at that point what what
does the word spiritual mean mean to you
in this context all right for foreplay
oh yeah yeah stuff you can't see you
know that's affecting us and you know we
all exist on many different levels like
you can't say you're mental you can't
see your thoughts you can't see your
emotions I mean yeah there are people
who can sort of see your energy field
around that but there's a lot of stuff
you can't see that's affecting us and I
use spiritual with a small s it's called
yeah and a lot of worlds out there and
you know it's possible to experience
those worlds you know if you if you
meditate if you practice certain
practices you can quiet yourself enough
to be able to tap into a lot of the
other levels that we actually exist on
so this level is just a schoolroom you
know but we are much bigger than all of
that so you can all know whatever you
want your soul your spirit or your
intuition your gut whatever you want to
call it there's the still small voice
essentially inside of all of us that's
tapped into all of this and it is part
of it so that that's a huge universe
what what does your meditation practice
look like these days or for people who
want to develop a meditation practice
but don't have one what do you recommend
maybe those are two different things
well it's a good you know I don't know
that I have a recommendation other than
follow your intuition I think I think
there's a perfect timing for all that
for everybody everybody is on a
spiritual path whether they know it or
not everybody's you know doing what
they're doing you know as a way to
fulfill you know something that they're
trying to complete here on the planet so
you know and it's all around it's it's
in everything so whatever is going to
allow you to be quieter and listen to
you as I say the universe is always on
so meditation is not like stopping the
universe or stopping anything it's as
quieting this sort of material out world
out here so you can pay attention to the
more subtle voices what what have you
taken from that if anything from that
initial experience that landed you in
hospital as you said you weren't cured
but he just became more cooperative as a
as a as a strategy that has informed
what you've done later or even what you
do today I mean we're there particular
insights or realizations that have
translated not really tell me with bit
more just the strength to get through
all that you know and and to come out
the other side and you know and and make
life work you know in the way that it
works for me so I can't I don't know
that there was any other you know
particular aha that happened other than
hmm well I think I will change my
attitude and shift my approach so that
it's much more effective and yeah so
that that that helped I mean having gone
through that there's not a lot there's
not a whole lot that's ears me out here
mmm-hmm that makes a lot of sense yeah I
mean once you've it's particularly true
I find with people who have been taken
to task in the sense of dealing with all
that is in here in addition to all that
is out there if that makes any sense
oh did you ever feel overwhelmed or
unfocused and if so what do you would
you do when you feel either of those
things
yeah come on it's not always every
vision you have every creative thought
you have everything you decide to do is
going to throw you out of your comfort
zone because you're gonna have to undo
what you were doing for and reconfigure
everything for the new game so you know
it's not like I'm you know totally
feeling overwhelmed I just don't let
myself go very long before I fix it you
know but as soon as I you know this huge
project that had this GTD summit was
quite you know there were many times
that I felt somewhat overwhelmed because
I wasn't quite sure what was gonna
happen over a lot of unknowns and so
forth of it that I didn't feel like I
could control that well and so you know
but you know I eat my own dog food as we
say
sit down light it down make next action
decisions hey what can I handle what can
I not handle yeah so yeah you know
everybody it's like surfers you're
always gonna fall off you just want an
ankle tether on so you can get back on
real quick and allows you sort of bigger
waves are there any new beliefs or
behaviors or habits that have materially
improved your life in the last handful
of years any any that come to mind
nothing comes to mind
except just our wonderful dog that we
had to put down a few months ago that
we're gonna need to get another you know
walking your dog and just being quiet
you know very cool uh I'm actually I'm
reading I'm reading a brand new book
right now that I was getting I was
getting shiatsu at a spa and my shiatsu
master who was working on me said by the
way because I went to sleep mr. breitler
by the way you have a little bit of
sleep apnea he said you must read this
book so I am halfway through this book
called the oxygen advantage the oxygen
advantage I had no idea how critical it
is to do nasal breathing instead of
mouth breathing it is amazing stuff
anyway so yeah there's a new habit the
oxygen is sleeping with you know
actually he suggests going and getting
adhesive cloth keep a four inch piece
and putting it over your mouth when you
go to sleep so that you if you train
yourself to you know you build the
practice of actually sleeping with nasal
breathing a fastening stuff the oxygen
advantage so that that's you mentioned
it that's a brand new brand new habit I
just started 48 hours ago are there are
there any particular books that you have
outside of your own that you have gifted
or recommended often to oh yes one of
the latest one is called the antidote
Oliver Berkman fabulous book totally
it's happiness for people who can't
stand positive thinking
or you love it I love it it's great it's
the the content is a good bit more
serious than what the title sounds like
he's really into kind of pooh-poohing
the people that just say oh don't have
any negative thoughts just go think
positive thoughts just and not not
accepting reality and so he he goes into
quite a bit of exploration of stoicism
and the you know I couldn't agree more
with actually his hypothesis and his
thinking anyway it's a fun book my wife
just broke out laughing regularly if she
was reading the book it's very well
written so that's that's one of my
latest recommendations the antidote all
right
note taken what is your if do you have a
consistent same morning routine of the
first hour or two of your day well when
you are outside of a gigantic event like
the summit that you just completed but
when you're in the sort of in-between
spaces around those larger commitments
you know tell me what I do regularly is
the night before I look at what my heart
I look at my calendar for the next day
or two and see what my heart landscape
is meaning one of the things I gotta do
you know no choice that in terms of
commitments that I've got so I know how
long to sleep I'm a huge fan of sleep
you know I used to think I was just lazy
but now given the new cognitive science
so I'm just smart we all need eight to
nine hours of sleep a night you know
unless you're really an exceptional
person so I love sleep so that's my
first thing is the night before just to
see how long I could sleep and want to
get up in the morning first thing I do
is a glass of lemon water I'm gonna
cleanse the system French press cup of
coffee
sooner or later a protein drink if we
have a dog the dog goes out I read the
New York Times on my iPad European
version and I'll probably play a game or
two of words with friends because I like
to get my brain sort of going I just you
know doing scramble with people around
the world and then whatever I feel like
doing next take a long bicycle ride
those canals in the Amsterdam usually I
got Catherine I usually go for it we
have a beautiful park about an eight
minute walk from where we are that that
we'd love to just walk around you know
just there's a nice way to clear your
head even when we don't have a dog we
you know get out get outside and it's
such a beautiful place here
that that helps to what what do you find
what do you wish GTD adherence or people
who were say have read the F read your
books once once through each would pay
more attention to are there any
particular aspects or concepts or
details that you that you wish more
people would pay attention to well I'm
not into having anybody change you near
the behavior they don't want to change
you know my job was just to get people
information whether they want it or not
I'm not gonna beat anybody up about it
or I'm not even gonna proselytize about
it very much as they look you want to
clear head here's how you good and you
do it or not
I hope here well I care otherwise I
wouldn't share this information because
it's it's potentially transformational
and life-changing for people when they
actually get this methodology and
capture clarify organize reflect and
engage with their stuff you know if they
do that but people can fall off on any
one of those a lot of people just don't
write everything down so they don't
trust their head or their lists a lot of
people don't decide next actions and how
it comes for stuff and so they're Lister
you know when they look at him creating
as much stress as they relieve and a lot
of people don't have a trusted
organization system that they trust a
big they're their head can absolutely
let it go knowing they're gonna see the
right thing at the right time be
reminded of the right stuff and awful a
lot of people don't step back and
reflect you know what we call the weekly
review or any kind of a regular
reflection review where you step back
and take an hour or two at least once a
week and bring up the rear garden and
you know and get current you don't get
clean again no because life is like that
and those are all the steps that people
don't take so I'd say hey guys read the
book again the book 20 times he says a
different book every time I read it
because you're ready for a different cut
on the stuff when you when you read it
again so there's all you know it sounds
like it's pretty simple but it's it's
you know quite a habit for most people
to change the weekly review I'd love to
spend just a few minutes on that could
you could you describe what the weekly
review might look like for someone what
is what are the status of the weekly
review well first of all let's step back
a second to Satan if you don't if you
haven't captured clarified organize it
and reviewed most of the stuff of your
life you don't have the whole thing to
review yet so it the weekly review that
the ideal weekly review means that your
system is relatively current at least
it's only a week old in terms of maybe
stuff that you haven't brought current
yet and then again even if you haven't
set up a system just to take an hour a
week and step back and look at your life
you know and say hey what's happened in
the last week what do I need to do about
that you know just any kind of a
thinking you know in a more reflective
process is going to help anybody you
know at any time and not just go zone
out you know drinker or even just
meditate but to really focus on your the
work of your life you know it's a
different focus you thinking about well
what did I commit to what's new what do
I need to be aware of if nothing else
just look at your calendar for that
coming up the next two or three weeks
you know everybody's gonna go oh that
reminds me
yeah no kidding you know so any of that
kind of stuff and again the more that
you have externalize your life and your
work the more valuable this review is
going to be when do you tend to do your
weekly reviews hmm did this enough you
don't have to say no time no I don't
really just just win sort of ambient
anxiety sort of creeps up on me but it's
usually about every seven days you know
years ago I actually read somewhere Tim
that the that because we've always said
we always knew just practically the
anyway that a weekly review was really
kind of critical to keep your system
currently live and well you know and
then it grows if you don't do that it
gets gets out-of-date you'll fall off
the wagon pretty fast and pretty
coherently
so but then I read went somewhere that
your brain actually if if you try to
recall something that happened within
the last seven days you can pretty well
recreate the context in your mind after
about seven or eight days it's kind of
like there's a part of your brain that
does a control-alt-delete and it's like
just trying to recreate something that
happened two weeks ago it's like can't
you find it what what where so there
seems to be some sort of a natural cycle
of a seven-day cycle you know in in in
in that kind of thinking so you know I
that is it's probably one of the most
challenging habits to set up but
certainly the most rewarding or if you'd
if you do do you have any rules or
Commandments for yourself four types of
things that you categorically say no to
and the reason I ask this is that I at
least of my own life have really tried
and found quite valuable figuring out
trying to figure out the single
decisions that remove many many many
decisions so for instance no to all
speaking engagements outside of Austin
Forex period of time whether it's six
months or 12 months or whatever it might
be
are there certain categories of things
that you simply say no to as a default
not really except unpleasant people I
don't know I I suppose this will change
but still at 73 I still take advantage
of every I think there's probably two or
three or maybe five interviews or
podcasts that we've refused because the
the sleaze factor was just too high but
I've done two thousand since the since
getting things done was published in
2001 I just I say hey anybody wants is
interested in this sure I'm here to
share with the world here we go
and you know I I don't have really
really that deep of pockets I haven't
been that entrepreneurial or
aspirational to go you know build this
huge fortune you know and so I still
take advantage of work that shows up and
if it seems interesting seems like you
know like something that people are
interested in me
doing like oh yeah you know my price is
going up so I'm not doing as much but
that's okay let's return to the
unpleasant people for a second
what if there is feeling gives you an
indicator that someone is a person you
want to avoid or is it more looking at
them online doing a little due diligence
in deciding this is not that the tone of
a person I want to interact with how do
you vet and filter those people I know I
don't have to do much about these days
to him I mean just given where I am in
my life people usually don't contact me
unless they're nice you know or at least
fun too you know and I have a little bit
of the of the what's-his-name I'd never
met on a guy that I didn't like you know
Will Rogers you know I have a little bit
of that in me and I think most people
are good people to begin with and most
people just don't come to me with
negative stuff you know I I guess maybe
in the old days are a little bit but I
kind of just made a joke again I would I
don't like my Pleasant people but I have
a blessed life and I have nothing but
you know pretty much Pleasant people
around me I'd like to read a short quote
and ask you to elaborate if you're able
because it seems to allude to something
very important this is from a Fast
Company piece some some time ago this is
a quote of of yours that they may have
gotten wrong so you can correct it if if
need be people assume that I am a
hard-working left-brained
results-oriented
OCD a and overattentive kind of guy he
says with a laugh in fact the reason
that I was attracted to this work was
that it allowed me to be more creative
more spontaneous freer I'm a freedom guy
could you explain what you mean by that
I self explanatory well well in the
sense that why does the at face value
someone might say that there are a lot
of rules this doesn't and this is this
is what some people asked like well it
seems like GTD is very rigid and has a
lot of process I want to be able to use
my intuition and creativity so that
that's
it it may be self-explanatory but I'd
like you to explain it anyway because it
doesn't sound totally obvious to
everybody yeah I think it was full bear
that said to be steady and well ordered
in your life so you could be crazy and
spontaneous in your work that was 120
years ago but he said that it's funny
people say I don't to be so structure I
said what do you think about the middle
line on the road out there you know it's
a constraint it's a limitation no center
line is great why it lets me think about
other things while I'm driving as
opposed to someone's gonna hit me so
just enough structure to give you the
freedom so I don't I don't structure
anything more than I need but you do
need a certain rigorous structure you
know well throw away your calendar if
you don't like lists come on it's just
the price of missing appointment is so
is emotionally pretty high that's why
the people they don't maintain that
structure pretty well right so you just
need as much structure as you need
ask any you know ask anybody out there
there was a it was a Picasso that said
inspiration is for amateurs it could
have been it sounds like no but in chair
paintbrush paint the canvas stare at it
you know discipline yourself anyway so I
think there is a the degree to which
that well I don't know it just seems so
700 STUV the people that that basically
that that I know some of the most
creative people I know all the most
creative guys I know and he just spoke
at the summit by the way he's and I sent
in a video so I know since he since he
was public about it I can make in public
probably the most one of the successful
entrepreneurs one actually the the ey
world entrepreneur of the year for 2019
Brad key well and Brad's he's on five
boards he teaches entrepreneurial isms
years of Chicago he don't Groupon and
sold it that's why he has its own Jeff
his new startup now it's like now is
four years old but even two years in had
a two billion dollar market gap this guy
is so smart so creative you know he
collects modern art he's you know he
runs the Chicago ideas week he started
it so this is probably one of the most
creative people you would ever meet
certainly one of the most productive
people you'd ever meet and I spent a
year with him people say well why would
he bring why would he do GTD I say well
his presenting issue with David I'm just
up to here he's not he was 27 he said
I'm just just getting my traction but I
wake up with million-dollar ideas but I
don't know what to do with him or where
to put them or who to get him to so he
just didn't need it more room so you
know this what what GTD does is it
provides space invariably if you capture
you know if you you know capture clarify
organize and reflect on all the things
that have your attention it will give
you more room what you do with that room
is unique to you some people use it to
be more creative some people use it to
be more strategic some people to be more
innovative some people to be just
present you know with whatever they're
doing one of my biggest champions a guy
named Howard Stern you can't find a more
creative guy too Howard you know he'd
tell you change his life gave them the
time to learn to paint which you always
wanted to do as well as keeps your his
radio going so you know are people like
Will Smith or Robert Downey jr. they big
champions of my stuff I could say their
names because they were public about
that so so you know if people think that
creative people you know can't use GTD
that's Nate oh there are a few people
you ought to meet a nitty gritty
question about the weekly review as a
few people ask this and I'm curious as
well is is the weekly review
inherently a solo process or do you ever
involve your staff in Oh weekly reviews
well I know people that would do weekly
reviews with their families very cool to
do I think you need to do your own
private one in any case no matter what
but then you if you have groups of
people to say what are the things that
we are all interested in as a group
that we can share and update each other
with so absolutely you know that's a
great it's a great time to do that
probably wouldn't necessarily frame it
so much as a weekly review so much as
let's review all the things that have
our attention as a team as a group as a
family as a couple do you manage your
email in a task manager or is it is it
its own system is it simply the email
client that you happen to be using
do you've any could you describe how
that the tools you use for for
processing email well I still use IBM
notes the old Lotus Notes but we still
use that on our company and I actually
had my CTO for 15 years Eric Mac built
an app that sits on top of or within
notes that lets me use email as my task
manager but you'd have to be using notes
to use it so it's not publicly available
unless you want to it's publicly
available if you wanted to set up Lotus
Notes or IBM notes and then get a
Productivity stick on it but that's you
know basically as I look at my screen
for instance I have navigator bars for
the left-hand side and they have my
Action List there's one of them says
projects one of them says agendas one of
them says calls when I'm says computer
one of them says creative writing one of
them says errands one of them says home
one of them says online one of them says
someday maybe and then waiting for and
so I can actually drag an email into any
one of those and it becomes that or I
can just open that folder and then add
anything to that folder that I want so
it's both an email manager as well as a
task manager at the same time
do you use any particular app or program
for pulling material like articles or
references off of web browsing into a
system of any time no not really
yes I use Evernote and you know I've
used the Evernote you know little
function that I know the letter
yeah the Web Clipper the Web Clipper but
I still don't use the depth much I don't
I have that much stuff that I want to do
about that you know the problem with
things like Evernote somebody described
it as as write only they spend all their
time adding stuff in there and don't
even go go in and look at what I got
yeah it's a risk with a lot of digital
[Laughter]
yeah edition edition and not
sufficiently well at least subtraction
from an attentional perspective any of
those things would work you know all you
need are lists basically and you just
need something to be among cut and paste
reference material and I've got
reference material all over Lotus Notes
I've got reference tutorial all over
Evernote of reference material and you
know and just in Word files all over I
don't have any particular template or
any particular suggestion other than you
know probably not a bad idea to every
once in a while maybe yearly curate all
of that stuff so you don't have a lot of
old dead wood in there
you've mentioned quite a few quotes you
seem to have a good memory for for
quotes of various types in in this
conversation so far
are there any quotes that you would
consider you try to live your life by or
think of often as a as a mantra slash
reminder of sorts so there any quotes
that come to mind as being particularly
important to you well my screensaver
just doesn't let go let go yeah hmm
controllers of the master addiction so
no no it's always a good idea to drop it
you know love life just you know be what
it is mm-hmm you know I often ask people
if you could get in if you could have
one gigantic billboard metaphorically
speaking to get a message out to
billions of people or could be a
question could be a quote could be a
word would that be like Oh or would it
possibly be something else for you I'd
have to give me that billboard that
opportunity let me see let me see what
shows up as I need to let go to be able
to see what showed up as opposed to try
to preconceived that I mean you're
having ideas not for holding hims not a
bad one just
you know prank practical you know G G
d/f you know I was reading a piece in
the Atlantic which which which I found
some of it very fascinating and this was
before you had applied the new labels to
the various vantage points so this was
back when we you were using Thea the
30,000 foot view and so on but you
mentioned at one point in this and again
feel free to fact-check but system
follows I think it is he met you where
he talks about beating you for dinner
after a seminar in Washington and
there's a portion here that that says
you know back in the old days this is
quoting you I had this naive idea that
people would see this cool tool or
offering and say okay what else we'd
have this great big Trojan horse it
would march into state corporate world
and let us find people were interested
in how life is really lived and they'd
say hey let's go discover XY and z truth
reality that sits behind all this stuff
but of course that never happened do you
still have that hope that people will do
something with the space that is created
related to bigger questions you know
come on after all these years i don't
you know i'm not a proselytizer I'm
really not I just think you know what I
what I've you know I've had the good
fortune to uncover something that that
allows people to create more space and
again what they do with that space is up
to them whether they want to use it to
be able to do their spiritual practices
people often say is this a spiritual
thing I guess everything is but no but
if you're in it if you're in a you know
if you're into practicing spiritual
practices this gives you a lot more
space to be able to do that in a quieter
way but again it's you know I don't I
people will do whatever they do the
people are already spiritual they just
may not be that aware of it but you know
I don't have any I'm not out trying to
get people to be something that they're
not or to you know uncover something
that or not and you know again you know
I've been doing this for 35 years you
know so at a certain point you go you
know people just do what they
let me just do the best work I can do
and you know just with what's in front
of me
completed with as much elegance and
excellence as I can and then the next
thing is going to show up you know that
was a big freeway aha moment I had years
ago when I was agonizing about what I
should do with my life in this little
still small voice inside of me said
David but you know don't worry you have
created so much in this life and
probably many others you don't have to
worry about that just complete whatever
is right in front of you with as much
excellence as you can and the next thing
will automatically show up and I haven't
turned back from that this that's
constantly been what's happened well
David I appreciate you making space for
this conversation where many many time
zones apart and I don't want to consume
too much of your finite time but I very
much appreciate you making space for
having this conversation and oh this was
fun nice to chat with you Tim event
Connect connect together yeah after all
these all this time after all this time
it's let's not wait so long no I'll let
you know when I'm when I'm headed to
Amsterdam because I do absolutely love
that city and people can find you of
course on Twitter at GTD guy at getting
things done calm is is there anything
else that you would like to say or share
or mention to people as we as we wrap up
oh you know the new edition of the book
that came out you know two or three
years ago is if you haven't got the new
edition it's really worth reading I
think you know I've dated a bunch of
stuff and you don't sort of tweak the
languaging a good bet a lot of people
really appreciated that and read it a
second time yeah I haven't read it but
once believe me it'll be a whole
different book and we're coming out with
a GTD workbook in September penguins
doing that it's kind of that ten moves
distrust free productivity because you
know the getting things done can be
quite daunting for people they pick up
the book and look at it at home I got
too much to do so kind of in the you
know in the in the genre of the the
workbook for the seven Habits that was
written in the workbook for some of the
other business guru books on enough to
have you written workbooks for before I
haven't but workbooks are really really
helpful it's I think that'll that will
really aid a lot of P
people and I've certainly found the
morning pages workbook and other things
like that to be scenario phille so I
will I will definitely check out the GTD
workbook and you said that's coming out
in September yep perfect any other any
other closing comments or
recommendations for people david river
or no i'm covered a you know you know if
there's one thing most people could
probably do more of its relax relax
enjoy life very little downside to at
least physically relaxed let it go is it
is it let go or let it go that's on your
screen saver but don't let go good
advice
everybody listening i will have links to
everything that we've spoken about in
the show notes as per usual at tim dot
blog forward slash podcast so to
everybody out there thank you for
listening and david once again really
appreciate the time this has been a real
pleasure and i have i will have a whole
extra set of notes here to follow up on
myself and really appreciate it thanks
to him my pleasure alright until next
time thanks hey guys this is Tim again
just a few more things before you take
off number one this is five bullet
Friday do you want to get a short email
from me would you enjoy getting a short
email from me every Friday and that
provides a little morsel of fun for the
weekend and five bullet Friday is a very
short email where I share the coolest
things I've found or that I've been
pondering over the week that could
include favorite new albums that I've
discovered it could include gizmos and
gadgets and all sorts of weird [ __ ] that
I've somehow dug up in the the world of
the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
dot-com that's for our work we
calm all spelled out and just drop in if
your email and you'll get the very next
one and if you sign up I hope you enjoy
it this episode is brought to you by
fresh books I've been talking about
fresh books for years now the all-in-one
invoicing payments and accounting
solution many entrepreneurs I know as
well as many contractors and freelancers
I work with all the time use it all the
time so I get to see fresh books on a
weekly basis fresh books makes it super
easy to track things like expenses
project time and client info and then
merge it all into great-looking invoices
fresh books can save users up to 200
hours per year on accounting and
bookkeeping tasks I don't know about you
but I like to do as little of that as
possible so 200 hours is a lot of hours
fresh books is always releasing new
features that make running your business
easier and here just a few of the major
upgrades they've made in the last 12
months alone number one they've
redesigned the time tracking feature to
create a more intuitive time tracking
experience number two they know just how
frustrating bank reconciliation can be
so they've automated bank reconciliation
removing the man number three they've
added ACH bank transfers that means you
now have an even faster way to collect
payment from your clients it's easy to
see how fresh books can grow with your
business and also help your business
grow just gives you more time to focus
on growing the business as opposed to
running the business and the admin stuff
they have plans to match your needs no
matter the size of your business from
the basic to comprehensive from small to
big and it all starts at just fifteen
dollars per month right now they're
offering it my listeners that's you guys
a free 30-day trial of fresh books you
can try it out with no credit card no
credit card is required just go to fresh
books calm slash Tim and enter Tim
Ferriss it's two hours two S's in the
how did you hear about us section that's
fresh books calm slash Tim and enter Tim
Ferriss in the how did you hear about us
section check it out first books calm
slash Tim
this episode of the tim ferriss show is
brought to you by 99designs 99designs is
a global creative platform that makes it
easy for you to find an amazing designer
and create designs you'll love from
logos to branding to packaging to books
you name it they have it and I've used
them for just about everything 99
designs is the go to creative resource
for any budget I've used them for years
now for foot covers for instance
mock-ups of before our body which went
on to become a number one year Times
best seller illustrations for the
multi-volume cow of Seneca including the
cover and many other creative projects
have been very impressed by the quality
of their work most recently I used 99
designs to update the illustrations and
layout of my five morning rituals ebook
the illustrations worked out great I
loved working with the designer is
selected and I plan to work with him on
more projects in the future and that's
something you can do you don't have to
start from scratch every time and right
now my listeners can get $20 off plus a
free $99 upgrade on their first design
contest simply submit a brief on the
site describing what you need and
designers who are interested in your
project often from around the world will
submit concepts for you to choose from
you refine as you go give feedback and
once you're ready you choose one to
finalize it's a great way to get started
and find the right match a great
designer and a great design at a great
price so head to 99 designs com forward
slash Tim to learn more or get started
today you can also see examples of some
of the work that I have done with
designers online and designs let's check
it out 99 designs comm forward slash tip
you